access granted holy [ __ ] what's  happening mr miller i'm looking for a  noel miller oh my god yeah that's that's  me man holy [ __ ] mr miller from the law  firm of  ligma slobben and rama  wow according to california lost section  3342 the owner of any dog is liable for  the damages suffered by a person who was  bitten by the dog i am here to inform  you on behalf of waleed muhammad that  you have hereby  been served  thank you where are you from again ligma  ligma slobben and rama not too long ago  me and zach fit a visit to uh noelle's  house it was all a ploy we have this dog  cute dog and next thing you know his  little dog runs up to my feet and goes  it was small so it didn't hurt at first  then i get home there's pus coming out  of my leg  infected we have photos we have evidence  i took it as soon as it happened too and  he's smiling too that's sick